vous êtes philosophe et mathématicien et
vous interrogez inlassablement les
travers de la modernité les dévoiements
de la rationalité ce qui de la part d'un
scientifique et particulièrement
éclairant or votre critique de
l'abstraction pour le derbit qu'on
retrouve dans la statistique dans les
formules chimiques dans un langage
d'experts et plus globalement dans la
rationalisation de la société permet
d'apporter un premier diagnostic de la
crise à la fois climatique et
civilisationnel que nous traversons au
fond et pour reprendre votre expression
la crise ne relève-t-elle pas d'une
question de taille
elle relève de beaucoup de choses entre
autres d'une question de taille
chose que je voudrais dire c'est que si
je suis un critique de la modernité ce
n'est pas en tant que la modernité
serait une époque forcément pire que les
autres c'est simplement que c'est la
mienne la modernité en tant que telle à
sa légitimité et à ses qualités mais
elle a aussi ses défauts et ses défauts
auxquels il ne faut pas être aveugle
pour éviter que une conduise à la
catastrophe mais depuis l'origine je
pense que l'humanité guettée par la
catastrophe et elle n'y échappe elle y
échappe précisément parce que les hommes
depuis qu'il y a des hommes sur la Terre
n'ont cessé de s'avertir des dangers
qu'il courait
donc la critique de la modernité est un
préalable à la catastrophe que charirait
également la modernité parce que vous
dites je critique la modernité parce que
j'en fais partie mais bon on est en
moins
elle a quand même des défauts qui lui
sont consubstant si elle va on va des
défauts et puis mais comme toutes les
époques ont eu des défauts
la particularité de notre époque c'est
que avec d'une part la multiplication
des hommes sur la Terre et
l'explosion des moyens technologiques et
ce qu'on appelle la mondialisation ou la
globalisation
les catastrophes qui auparavant étaient
limité risque elle-même aujourd'hui de
devenir globale une des choses qui nous
menace particulièrement aujourd'hui
c'est une certaine forme de cécité aux
enjeux
essentiels qui se jouent sur le plan
quantitatif parce que en fait le
quantitatif lorsqu'on passe certains
seuils et bien ça devient du ça devient
du qualitatif j'ai été particulièrement
rendu attentif à ces questions là par
mon passé de mathématiciens puisque en
mathématiques je m'occupais d'équation
dérivée partielle non linéaire qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire non linéaire c'est à
dire quand les variables varient
proportionnellement les unes par rapport
aux autres la seule différence qui est
entre le petit et le grand c'est
précisément juste la taille en revanche
quand on a des liens non linéaires
ce qu'il se passe c'est que à certains
moments on a des effets de seuil qui
peuvent nous faire basculer d'un certain
régime dans un autre régime complètement
complètement différent dans les sciences
physiques on connaît très très bien ça
des exemples emblématiques de ça ce sont
les transitions de phase si on prend de
l'eau et qu'on la chauffe lorsque sous
une pression atmosphérique normale on
arrive à 100 degrés tout d'un coup l'eau
se transforme en vapeur là on a très un
très bel exemple si vous voulez on a une
transformation quantitative augmentation
de la température qui tout d'un coup
produit un effet qualitatif dramatique
ce que entre l'eau et la vapeur le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que la
différence c'est énorme ça ça se
rencontre partout en sciences physiques
ça se retrouve aussi en biologie et
évidemment ça se retrouve également à
l'intérieur des sociétés humaines alors
il faut faire attention à pas forcément
les analogies entre ce qui se passe en
physique en biologie et dans le monde
humain il y a une phrase de Georges
ganguilhem que j'ai toujours en tête qui
dit pour un organisme l'organisation
c'est son fait pour les sociétés
humaines c'est leur affaire voilà mais
cela n'empêche pas que dans tous les
domaines les questions de taille sont
absolument
essentiels et que si on n'y est pas
attentif et ben on va au devant de de
surprise qui peuvent être
catastrophiques et précisément on y est
pas attentif et on n'y est pas attentif
parce que ça fait partie justement du
rêve moderne que de ne pas avoir de
limite alors comment faire pour revenir
à la limite certes mais bon il y a deux
choses il y a effectivement
un mouvement moderne qui considère la
limite non pas comme quelque chose à
respecter mais a priori comme quelque
chose à transgresser moi je fais partie
d'un organisme le CNRS qui a pour dans
son logo inscrit dépasser les frontières
donc on voit bien là l'ambition moderne
on attribue à Hercule en antiquité le
fait d'avoir écrit sur les colonnes qui
portent son nom les colonnes d'Hercule
neckplus ultra pas plus loin et Charles
Quint avait pris comme devises de son
empire plus sous le trap plus loin et
voilà on voit le basculement qu'il y a
entre on pourrait dire une sagesse
ancienne qui prenait les limites et un
mouvement moderne qui va vers leur
déplacement alors là aussi il faut faire
attention de ne pas idéaliser les
anciens parce que si les anciens
s'avertissaient des dangers qu'il y
avait à transgresser certaines limites
c'est que ils avaient tendance une
tendance très forte à les franchir mais
au moins s'avère s'avertissait-il des
dangers c'est vrai qu'avec la modernité
on l'idée que toute limite
est promise à être dépassée mais d'autre
part l'inconscience qu'il y a autour du
fait que il y a des effets de seuil qui
ce qui fait que ce qu'on imaginait
obtenir en franchissant certaines
limites ne correspond pas du tout parce
que précisément des bouleversements
qualitatifs apparaissent et il y a
vraiment une cécité là très particulière
de la modernité assez à ces questions de
taille alors une des raisons que je
pourrais voir à cette à ce fait
c'est la grande séparation qui s'est
opérée dans dans l'université moderne
disons avec la philosophie qui a été
versée du côté des lettres et les
mathématiques qui ont été versées du
côté des sciences
ce qui fait que la philosophie a
abandonné je dirais le domaine du
quantitatif aux sciences et aux
mathématiques et le philosophe a eu
tendance à se cantonner à un domaine
conceptuel où il ignore tout du
quantitatif ce qui est très
problématique parce que les concepts
eux-mêmes ont un domaine de validité qui
qui doit prendre en compte un certain
horizon quantitatif si on prend la
démocratie aujourd'hui classiquement à
des élèves on va apprendre que la
démocratie ça n'est à Athènes au 5e
siècle avant Jésus-Christ certes avec
beaucoup d'imperfections mais quand même
mais on fait comme si il y avait une
essence de la démocratie qui pouvait se
conserver
inchangé entre une cité où il y avait
quelques dizaines de milliers de
citoyens et puis je ne sais pas moi l'un
de moderne où il va y avoir bientôt un
milliard et demi d'habitants
pratiquement un milliard de gens
inscrits sur les listes électorales et
pour moi c'est un peu
rangé aussi bien la tête du 5e siècle
avant Jésus-Christ que les États-Unis ou
que l'Inde moderne sous la même rubrique
de démocratie c'est un peu comme si on
rangeait dans la même catégorie les
vaches et les tables au prétexte que les
deux ont quatre pieds
bon c'est sûr que dans les deux cas il y
a des procédures de vote mais
le fonctionnement général n'a absolument
rien à voir et donc dans les deux cas
parler de démocraties
employer le même mot c'est se condamner
un aveuglement total aux effets de seuil
qui qui interviennent lorsque une
population dépasse certains seuils entre
les deux il y a quand même eu quelques
révolutions épistémologiques et
notamment la transformation du cosmos en
univers on va dire pour prendre le titre
d'Alexandre alors justement aujourd'hui
on a l'impression qu'on prône un retour
au cosmos alors peut-être juste en mode
vocabulaire pourquoi la terminologie
cosmos plutôt que univers le mot cosmos
en grec ancien
ça signifiait au départ un ensemble
harmonieux bien ordonné
c'est ce sens là que l'on a chez Homer
quand Agamemnon range son armée en bien
en ordre de bataille pour aller attaquer
trois son armée est cosmique parce que
elle est elle est bien rangée
et on en a encore un signe en français
moderne dans le mot cosmétique qui vient
de cosmético c'est c'est ce qui un
cosmétique c'est ce qui est fait pour
rendre dans la mesure du possible
évidemment dans mon cas c'est difficile
mais très plus harmonieux voilà et quand
les premiers philosophes grecs vers le
6e siècle avant Jésus-Christ on
cherchait un mot pour désigner
l'ensemble de ce qui est ça n'existait
pas en fait ils ont été pêchés ce mot
cosmos ça voulait dire que il d'emblée
il considérait que l'ensemble de ce qui
est est un ensemble
harmonieux bien ordonné et à ce moment
là la mission d'un être humain à
l'intérieur du cosmos c'est de s'insérer
comme il convient à l'intérieur de cet
ordre qui est harmonieux et ce qui va se
passer à l'époque moderne alors le grand
événement c'est l'avènement du système
de Copernic c'est comme cela d'ailleurs
qu'on comprend à quel point les mois a
été grands autour de cet événement du
système de parce que c'est vraiment un
changement de d'univers mental énorme
parce que dans un cosmos chaque chose
était à la place qui lui revenait en
fonction de sa nature et donc si la
terre était au centre il faut voir que
le centre c'était pas le meilleur lieu
du cosmos mais c'était au contraire le
pire et puis au fur et à mesure qu'on
montait dans les sphères célestes et
bien on allait vers toujours mieux c'est
pour ça quand on était au septième ciel
ça c'est encore un fossile dans notre
langue d'aujourd'hui de cette ancienne
conception vraiment on était dans un
état extrêmement enviable et en fait on
avait cette opposition entre montres
terrestre et monde céleste si on prend
au sérieux le système de Copernic
l'opposition entre monte terrestre et
mon céleste n'a plus aucun sens puisque
la terre est un astre pareil aux autres
mais à partir du moment où on perd cette
distinction terrestre céleste toutes les
distinctions cosmiques sont dévalorisées
et à ce moment là on se retrouve dans ce
que l'univers l'univers infini et ça va
avoir un des effets considérable puisque
dans un cosmos le monde est considéré
comme bien ordonné il y a une sorte
d'articulation entre les questions de
fait et ce que les modernes vont appeler
les questions de valeurs alors que
justement avec la modernité on va avoir
une séparation entre les questions de
fait qui on va s'occuper la science et
de l'autre côté la morale les valeurs
mais qui est complètement déracinée de
tout ancrage dans les choses on divorce
entre les valeurs et les faits on entre
dans le champ moderne dans le paradigme
moderne dont vous dites que finalement
on continue d'être dans ce paradigme
moderne et c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles notre rapport au monde c'est
complètement transformé alors vous
prenez comme exemple l'usage des mots
par exemple le mot haut qui raconte un
petit peu notre enfin l'évolution de
notre rapport au monde
dans l'ancienne pensée cosmique donc
l'eau était un des éléments fondamentaux
avec la terre l'air et le feu
et si on prend des premiers
dictionnaires français qui apparaissent
au XVIIe siècle en particulier à la fin
du XVIIe siècle le dictionnaire de
furtières l'eau est encore définie comme
un des quatre éléments et puis plutôt
qu'une définition de l'eau on a une
énumération des endroits où rencontre
l'eau donc il y a l'eau de mer l'eau de
rivière l'eau du puits bon et puis si on
prend à n'importe quelle dictionnaire
actuel on a en gros c'est la définition
c'est haut liquide incolore inodore sans
saveur à l'état pur
formé par combinaison d'oxygène et
d'hydrogène et de formule chimiques H2O
voilà et là en fait quand vous prenez la
définition de l'eau 17e et la définition
de l'eau au 21e siècle on sur cet
élément pourtant si simple on mesure
l'ampleur de la transformation
et avec ses avantages et ces
inconvénients il est clair que
les sciences mathématiques de la nature
dont la chimie fait partie qui
aboutissent à cette définition de l'eau
comme H2O ont permis aussi une maîtrise
technologique absolument extraordinaire
ce qui fait que l'eau maintenant c'est
d'abord pour nous dans nos pays ceux qui
coule au robinet ma mère quand elle
était
institutrice
l'année elle devait corriger ce qui
restait du certificat d'études et il y
avait une question qui était posée au
candidat qui était quels sont les trois
états de l'eau et il y avait un des
candidats qui avait répondu l'eau du
robinet l'eau des WC lot de piscine
bon on attendait plutôt l'eau liquide la
glace et la vapeur d'eau mais enfin bon
mais ce qui était très touchant
finalement dans cette réponse c'était
que le candidat en question avait une
définition qui était semblable à celle
de furtières
il disait l'eau de rivière l'eau de mer
l'eau de la source mais sauf que lui là
où il rencontrait l'autre c'était
d'abord au robinet au WC et à la piscine
bon mais ce qu'il y a c'est que si
justement aujourd'hui les habitants des
grandes métropoles rencontrent l'eau de
cette manière-là c'est parce que il y a
toute une infrastructure technologique
qui nous amène l'eau qu'il a fait couler
à volonté en plus une eau qui a été
traitée de telle sorte que on risque pas
de s'empoisonner avec enfin il faut
absolument panier l'immense confort que
cela nous apporte mais ce que l'on perd
aussi
c'est un certain rapport direct aux
éléments qui appauvrit grandement notre
notre humanité puisqu'on a tendance
aujourd'hui à réduire le monde au
service qu'il peut nous rendre mais
avant de nous rendre des services la
nature est d'abord un vis-à-vis qui nous
aide aussi à nous comprendre nous-même
moi j'étais très marqué par les écrits
de Bachelard d'autant que je fais partie
d'un institut l'Institut d'histoire de
philosophie des sciences et des
techniques dont Bachelard a été
directeur pendant 15 ans de 1940 à 1955
et ce qui est très intéressant chez
Bachelard c'est que d'un côté il s'est
passionné pour les sciences de son temps
mais en même temps il y a une seconde
partie dans son oeuvre où il va se
consacrer aux différents éléments écrit
la psychanalyse du feu l'air et les
songes et la terre et les rêveries du
repos etc et un livre qui est consacré à
l'eau qui s'appelle l'eau et les rêves
et voyez bien que on peut écrire un
livre qui s'appelle les rêves on peut
pas écrire un livre H2O et les rêves H2O
non il y a aucun rêve or le rêve ça fait
quand même partie aussi de notre
humanité
une chose qui a subi ce désenchantement
et en même temps une forme de
sacralisation ce qui est paradoxal c'est
la vie est-ce que vous pourriez en dire
un mot pour ah oui
il faudra encore cet un mot extrêmement
riche et alors là c'est aussi
extraordinaire de constater dans les
dictionnaires la l'évolution de la
manière dont on
la définit si on dit comme Littré que la
vie c'est
bon l'ensemble des fonctions qui
caractérisent les
êtres vivants la nutrition
la digestion enfin voilà toutes ces
fonctions là dans les évangiles de
Jésus-Christ de je suis le chemin la
vérité et la vie bon il dit pas je suis
je suis la nutrition la digestion etc on
voit bien que là il y a pas il y a pas
du tout synonyme et ça c'est un des
choses qui m'avait
mis ma très mal à l'aise à l'époque de
l'épidémie de covid où il avait été dit
que on ferait on mettrait tout en oeuvre
pour
sauver des vies quelle est la définition
qu'on donnait aux movie et dans les
faits avec le décompte des morts qu'on
avait tous les jours finalement ce qu'on
voulait maintenir c'était des vies au
sens biologique
la fonction vitale il fallait que ça se
ça continue et on s'interrogeait pas
tellement sur ce que c'était que une vie
humaine voyait c'est un mot très riche
en français quand on dit
c'est pas une vie ça veut dire que une
vie humaine ne doit pas être menée de de
cette manière là or alors même que on a
toujours la nutrition la digestion enfin
toutes les fonctions vitales qui
fonctionnent et au fond la façon dont on
a entendu le mot vie lors de la pandémie
par exemple et cette idée que la vie
doit être ce qui doit être conservé à
tout prix c'est un peu la même
définition que les transhumanistes
oui enfin même ça vient de beaucoup plus
loin parce que alors là on a un énorme
énorme différence aussi entre la pensée
ancienne et médiévale et la pensée
moderne dans sa physique Aristote
définit les objets de la physique quels
sont les objets de la physique les
animaux les plantes et puis les éléments
terre r oufe mais vous voyez que dans
son numération des objets de la physique
ça commence par le vivant les animaux
les plantes et c'est normal parce que en
grec fusils qui a donné le mot le mot
physique
qu'on traduit en latin par Natura et
chez dans la langue moderne nature
la fusée au verbe fuyen qui veut dire
naître croître ce qui se présente de
soi-même et bon bah c'est le vivant qui
est évidemment l'emblème de cela et ça
veut dire que pour Aristote et pour les
anciens en réalité le monde est pensé à
partir du vivant en latin Natura c'est
lié aussi
naître nature Nativité c'est la même
racine
quant au XVIIe siècle Galilée dit le
livre de la nature est écrit en langue
mathématique on change complètement de
monde d'ailleurs là on retrouve encore
l'importance du système de Copernic
parce que pour les anciens donc il y
avait monde terrestre monde céleste
alors le monde céleste était le monde
des régularités et donc comme c'était un
monde régulier on pouvait l'appréhender
par les mathématiques parce que les
objets mathématiques sont eux-mêmes
immuables en revanche sur la terre où il
y a du vivant où ça amenait ça meurt
enfin bon ça pourrit bon les
mathématiques sont inadaptées
du moment où on abolit la distinction
entre terrestre céleste c'est ça qui
permet à Galilée de dire bon bah puisque
les mathématiques c'était vrai tout le
monde le reconnaît dans le monde céleste
et qui a pas de différence pour le monde
terrestre et le monde céleste et bien
les mathématiques doivent être valables
partout et on a remporté des des succès
absolument extraordinaires en
particulier Newton à la fin du XVIIe
siècle avec sa loi de la gravitation
universelle qui montre que ce sont les
mêmes équations qui régissent la
trajectoire des astres dans le ciel et
la chute des corps sur terre bon
extraordinaire mais ce qui se passe
c'est que malgré tout à un moment donné
on va rencontrer des problèmes c'est
avec le vivant parce que le vivant
résiste à la mathématisation qu'est-ce
qui fait que
spontanément autour de nous on fait la
distinction entre le non-vivant et le
vivant c'est qu'on repère spontanément
dans le vivant le fait que le vivant il
a un principe d'animation interne c'est
à dire que il ne se comporte pas
uniquement en fonction des forces
externes qui qui s'exerce sur lui mais
que il a un principe interne et ce
principe interne m'a précisément
justement on peut pas l'objectiver bon
alors il y a beaucoup de choses
objectivables dans le vivant mais le
vivant en tant que tel n'est pas il y a
quelque chose il y a quelque chose
direct du type et alors les biologistes
vont se retrouver dans une situation
très inconfortable parce que d'un côté
ils étudient le vivant mais de l'autre
côté comme ils ont envie que leur
science soit une science au sens moderne
du terme ils ont énormément de mal à
reconnaître ce qu'on appelle la
téléologie la finalité à l'intérieur des
êtres vivants finalement il va y avoir
une formation de compromis qui va
émerger qui est que on aime bien forcer
de reconnaître à l'intérieur du vivant
que il y a une finalité mais on va
réduire cette finalité à un seul
principe qui est le principe de
conservation et de multiplication et en
fait c'est une conception extrêmement
pauvre du vivant puisqu'on ne considère
pas le vivant en tant que ce qu'il a en
tant que vivant particulier à être mais
simplement en tant que
être qui cherche à se à se conserver et
c'est là qu'on peut faire le lien avec
le transhumanisme parce qu'on pourrait
dire que la mission première d'un être
humain c'est d'accomplir un destin
humain mais d'un autre côté si vous
dites non en fait notre seule mission
c'est de vivre le plus longtemps
possible bon bah à ce moment là on peut
imaginer toutes les transformations
possibles pour
prolonger le processus vital vous voyez
chez saint Thomas d'Aquin il dit un âne
ne souhaite pas devenir cheval car il
cesserait d'être un âne vous voyez l'âne
sa première mission sur terre c'est
d'être un bon
âne comme il va pas certes s'il était un
cheval il pourrait courir plus vite mais
il serait pas il serait plus un âne mais
si on réduit la vie uniquement à sa
conservation bon bah à ce moment-là il y
a plus d'objections donc c'est là où on
voit que tout se tient
Olivier Rey quel est le rôle du
philosophe dans la cité est-ce que
justement c'est de remettre la question
du du nombre au cœur de la réflexion et
ce qu'il doit devenir roi de la
République est-ce qu'il est l'ermite ou
conseiller du prince ou encore autre
chose
j'ai l'impression que pendant longtemps
la philosophie elle s'est forçait de
penser l'être ensuite quand le monde
s'est mis à se transformer de manière de
plus en plus rapide sa grande mission ça
a été de penser le devenir et
aujourd'hui ce serait je dirais ça va
tellement vite que ce serait essayer de
penser ce qui nous arrive en fait
l'auteur dag dit le rôle du philosophe
aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer de penser
dans la valence voilà ça ça on est dans
pris dans un gigantesque processus donc
je dirais moi ce que j'essaye de faire
c'est de penser ce processus ce qui nous
arrive sans s'illusionner sur le fait
que on puisse y changer grand chose
parce que précisément le processus est
devenu tellement puissant et tellement
gigantesque vous voyez quand on est dans
une avalanche la seule chose qu'on
puisse faire c'est d'attendre que que ça
se calme un peu parce que là dans la
valanche bon on est pris on est pris
dedans cela étant ce que je pense et que
ce processus est en train de se de
s'effilocher de se déliter gravement
que au cours du 21e siècle il va y avoir
des bouleversements très très importants
et que si on reste complètement pris
dans le processus justement on ne pourra
vivre les turbulences à l'intérieur du
processus que comme des catastrophes
alors que d'un autre côté c'est aussi
des chances que nous aurons précisément
de rouvrir des possibilités de vie qui
aujourd'hui sont canalisés dans une
seule direction et donc que je dirais
qu'à ce moment-là la philosophie elle
retrouvera le rôle que lui a signé
Nietzsche dans l'Antiquité c'était de
d'inventer des possibilités de vie
le philosophe qui vous a construit
alors justement là j'ai prononcé le mot
de niche alors je dirais pas que
Nietzsche m'a construit mais c'est
vraiment par lui que je suis
monsieur intéressé à la philosophie que
je suis entré dans la philosophie je
dirais que la première caractéristique
de Nietzsche par rapport à d'autres
philosophes c'est que c'est quelqu'un
quand on est jeune qui vous demande
quelque chose en fait je dirais pas que
Nietzsche est un constructeur d'un
certain point de vue il est plutôt
indestructeur mais c'est un éveilleur
alors même si on l'a compris est-ce que
vous pourriez formuler en une phrase la
grande question philosophique
d'aujourd'hui
bon s'il faut en choisir une je dirais
redonner un sens positif à la limite
voyez dans un cosmos
la limite à un sens positif puisque
comme l'ensemble est conçu comme
harmonieux bien ordonné il faut
respecter la mesure la modernité et
justement ça c'est à les grands enjeux
de du passage du monde clos cosmos à
l'univers infini
la limite
devient toujours un obstacle à franchir
elle est soit déniée soit quand on la
reconnaît on la reconnaît comme
contrainte c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans l'écologie si vous
voulez il y a toute une écologie qui va
dire regardez on ravage la terre donc il
faut
se restreindre mais on se restreint
parce que parce qu'on peut pas faire
autrement parce que sinon on détruit
tout mais si on pouvait
continuer comme on le fait il y aurait
pas de d'objections si vous voulez dans
l'écologie actuelle la véritable
motivation c'est ça où la mort mais on
pourrait dire que la limite c'est
d'abord une question de de vertu
ça c'est je pense que ce serait vraiment
une tâche très importante que de d'être
capable de recevoir la limite comme
éminemment positive comme ceux qui fait
être ce qui donne forme ce qui fait
échapper à l'informe ce qui est du
ressort de ce qui est de du ressort de
la vertu alors cela étant sur ce terrain
là il faut reconnaître que la
philosophie n'est peut-être pas la
meilleure
instance les mythes étaient beaucoup
plus efficace que la philosophie voyez
dans l'Antiquité cette sagesse là ce
véhicule est d'abord par les mythes bien
avant de l'aide par la philosophie il y
a aussi la littérature il y a le
narratif je pense et peut-être plus
efficace que le spéculatif pour redonner
un sens positif à la limite on a besoin
d'aide merci beaucoup Olivier c'est moi
qui vous remercie